[Music]
yo what's up guys mkbhd here welcome
back to another video and i was just
thinking you know what we haven't done
since
the last decade
a q a so that's what we're doing here
answering some of your questions from
twitter i asked you guys what you wanted
to know over there as i usually do and
we got some good ones
so let's get into it also i want you to
you see this back here stay right here
don't move i want to show you something
see how far away this looks like pretty
clear
you can kind of tell what that is but up
close
it's a bunch of
lego pieces this came in the mail from
asus so thanks for sending it along but
it's literally a lego
it's a it's a lego brick version of my
profile picture i put a video of this up
on twitter of like zooming out for it
it's kind of cool how they use the
different colors there's absolutely no
blue in my profile picture but it's like
the farther away you get the more clear
it is and these are real they're real
lego bricks so that was that was kind of
cool i don't think they're like
making this any more often than this one
of one but i wanted to share it i'm
gonna put it back there you go
there it is now you can tell
very cool all right let's get into your
questions see if you guys have gotten
better at asking questions for 2020.
okay here's one why is your new intro
not in dark mode as the twitter should
always be um i'm a really big fan of the
new intro graphic and the new outro
graphic that matches it there will be
other alternate versions of the intro
for different types of videos and
different playlists series and styles
over the course of the year so stay
tuned for those some of them may be dark
mode
spoiler but uh yeah i really like it so
that's the the default one for now how
dope is the new raven model s oh yes ben
sullins from teslanomics the new model s
is great so for those who don't know
apollo
has been retired so three years in it
was a lease so after the three years i
extended it for a little bit and then
she has gone back to tesla and i have a
new model s now it's wrapped matte black
it's almost the same exact car the new
name is phantom and there's a little
extra work done it's a car that i own
now uh so i could do stuff like tint the
windows and make it a little more custom
but yeah it has been amazing so far like
i said very similar car still the
high-end performance model s same
dimensions same design
but there are some new things like uh
there's new cameras there's new software
features there's actually more range new
suspension new front motor i've actually
thought about making a video maybe leave
a thumbs up if you'd want to see an
entire video on all the new changes and
stuff that's different about phantom
versus apollo or what how teslas change
over time but it's fascinating there is
no
2020 model s they just slowly
increment the car over time so it is a
better car okay what do you think is the
most overrated trend in 2019 that you
don't want to see continue wow
you know in tech
you don't really get to find out what's
overrated in the moment it sort of takes
a while before things that used to be
very popular
fizzle away
so a lot of the stuff we're living now
like you know more cameras higher fresh
rate screens bigger batteries that sort
of stuff we won't find out if it's
overrated or not until maybe it goes
away oh you know what i will say though
since he says stuff that you don't want
to see continue
um the g8 and the pixel 4 both had this
this like gesture control where you're
like waving over the top of the phone to
do stuff
the both of them didn't really work very
well um
and even if they did work well i didn't
use them very often so i will say
it's not even overrated but i just don't
want to see that in the next pixel or
the next lg g phone
gesture controls so what are your goals
for the next decade
that is a big question um
and i am notoriously i already know i'm
not very good at thinking really far
into the future i'm so
laser focused on making the next video
better and making the next couple weeks
and the next year of videos
better than last year but yeah now that
we've looked back over the last decade
and we've seen how this whole
tech thing this whole reviewer thing
has grown
i i basically have some future thoughts
about
about reviewing things
period and i think there may be a way to
take reviewing things
to the next level but that's all i don't
want to reveal too much so that's all
i'll say for now oh yeah when are you
moving to the new studio
uh this is something that i've teased a
little bit uh so we have a new space in
this same building that we're going to
be moving into it was supposed to be
they said it's construction so
construction is never on time but we're
originally going to move on new year's
now the new date we have is
february 1st
which is in a couple weeks
but that's the plan is to move
everything we have in this studio
and the two spaces we have that are
right next to the studio and move them
all into this bigger space and uh
that'll that'll be pretty fun and we'll
get to take everything we know about
furnishing a space and what we want to
do with it and to have a podcast and
different sets and different rooms and
sound proofing and all this stuff we'll
be able to take all of our expertise
from these spaces that we've set up and
move it into this one like dream tech
studio that's the plan anyway so i'll
keep you guys posted i'll probably have
like a behind the scenes of how we build
it out but
that's gonna be fun
uh are you more hyped about flexible
phones or flexible tvs
and actually maybe that ties back to one
of the earlier questions so the answer
is flexible phones being able to fold up
something and put it in your pocket is
of course ideally useful when a tech
works out but i don't know if you
remember
curved tvs do you guys remember curved
tvs
that would be
one of the most overrated
silly useful things i actually did a
video with the curve tv i remember back
when i was in college and that was
around the year at ces where ces is
basically a tv show at this point most
of what you see there is going to be tvs
anyway there were a lot of curve tvs
that year at ces and a lot of curved tvs
came out afterwards and i got one and it
was kind of cool but
we don't really see that anymore okay so
has the pro display xdr
made you
want to start releasing hdr content
regularly
um really interesting question i've
actually thought about two things that
it's made me want to do so having the
new mac pro and the new 6k pro display
xdrs have made me want to consider
uploading in 8k
and uploading in hdr now uploading an 8k
you know just for the hell of it i'm
going to upload this video in 8k i'm
going to make an 8k timeline and i won't
scale anything down this will be one
giant 8k video even though i know
no one's gonna watch it in 8k
even if you could you probably don't
have the 8k screen to watch it in but
the mac pro is so capable that i've
thought about i could probably just
upload 8k starting like now but i'm not
going to do that quite yet for 2020 but
the other thing that i have thought
about is uploading an hdr now the hdr
pipeline and the workflow for uploading
to youtube
is
interesting to say the least i've
watched a couple hdr videos and if you
have an hdr compatible phone any new
phone now
you can watch hdr videos as well
but the difference between watching a
video that's hdr on one of these hdr
screens and a non-hdr screen
is actually bigger than i thought so a
lot of these videos that look amazing in
hdr that i would love to just start
doing all my videos in hdr
when you watch them like on a non-hdr
screen which a lot of people still have
they look worse than normal videos
and so that was sort of a tough
place for me to to find myself i don't i
don't want to upload a worse than normal
looking video so yeah i i could i'll
probably do
the kind of what john morrison did you
could do a single video or two a one-off
thing in hdr i'll probably do the pro
display xtr review in hdr but uh i don't
know about everything being hdr yet but
you know enjoy the 8k video okay what
are you most excited for at ces
yeah so i'm flying tomorrow to ces ces
is next week and this will be my eighth
consumer electronics show saying that
out loud makes me feel really old but
it's true i'll be there and there is
some interesting stuff that we've seen
the show has its ups and downs i think
this year there's going to be a little
bit more smartphone stuff than usual we
have samsung who just announced their
samsung galaxy note 10 lite and s10 lite
very curiously they will be at the show
i believe and if they are i'll go to the
samsung booth and check them out and
share what i find but they seem to be
weirdly like overlapping with the galaxy
s10e and lower end samsung phones but
also higher end because they're bigger
screens they're weird i'll check those
out and then oneplus has also promised
they're going to be showing a concept
phone now ces is always full of concepts
and things that will never go on sale
but what they showed was really
interesting it was a little bit of a
teaser of essentially a disappearing
camera and if that's the only trick on
the phone and that's cool by itself but
it seems like some sort of a chromatic
glass that can hide the camera bump or
hide the cameras on the back and then
unhide them it doesn't really matter too
much to me because i'm not looking at
the back of the phone a lot i don't
really mind seeing the cameras but that
could be really cool i will definitely
be checking that out and a bunch of tvs
again it's always going to be a very tv
heavy show there's going to be a lot of
pixels a lot of q led a lot of oled a
lot of hdr a lot of 8k 4k
all of that will be at ces matter of
fact here's what you can do if you do
see something cool in a headline or
something on twitter that you want to
see a video about that's at ces tweet it
at me so i'm gonna go out there and
obviously be at ces very soon and i'll
see those tweets and i'll go find those
things on the show floor and point a
camera at them and see if they're any
good so if you find cool stuff send it
my way and maybe it'll end up in a dope
tech of ces video at the end of the show
that's what will be the best version of
this hopefully it's a good show okay
each morning what order do you open your
apps
on your phone
so
alarm app i close the alarm on my phone
first thing
twitter
instagram
gmail
and then tick tick my tasks app on
android and ios
and then i'm out then i'm off to the day
oh yeah how was lasik
uh
best thing i've ever spent my money on
honestly it was funny in the months
leading up to it i knew i wanted to do
it in 2019 so i could be seeing 2020 by
2020 and i was watching all these
reviews and people talking about lasik
and
99 of people were like this is the best
thing i've ever done and then one
percent were like you could die
you know which a lot of people were sure
to email me those articles but i was
still confident but i eventually went
through with it it's been almost a month
since i did it and
it's been great the number one side
effect most people have is dry eye
right now it's the middle of winter in
new jersey it's about as dry as it gets
out here and my dry eye is is pretty
much over already two you see little
halos around stuff for like the first
couple days while driving at night but
like i drove the day after lasik and i
could see actually better than 2020
2015.
so
i feel like it was worth it i really
don't spend money on much other than
tech so spending money on myself
investing in myself and and being able
to see better than i even could with
contacts or glasses
i'd say it's worth it definitely uh 10
out of 10 would recommend so will we
ever see a video to see how you pack
your tech for events specifically how do
you get the imac pro onto a plane
i'll show you i have one gigantic
pelican case that's a checked bag i'll
link it below if you want to know about
it it's got the styrofoam cutouts just
for the imac pro it slots in there
perfectly over the top of a keyboard and
a mouse and some hardware and that's
pretty much it lock it up check it in
oversized baggage pay a little extra for
it bring an imac pro now we got why
don't you use end screens on your videos
to promote more of your content here you
go i'll do it i'll do it for this one
ready there it is right there
that's been it
thanks for watching hey if you got any
other questions feel free to hit me up
on twitter i'm always on there but i'm
heading out to ces
if you find cool stuff tweet it at me
let me know
we'll point a camera at it we'll see if
it's any good and then we'll come back
and we'll do more podcast stuff and more
videos i'll get into 2020. thanks for
watching
catch you guys later
peace